une direction à présent la russie pour
la troisième et avant-dernière journée
du 24e forum économique de
saint-pétersbourg en plusieurs milliers
de chefs d'entreprises et d'acteurs
politiques réunis en cette fin de
semaine pour échanger sur l'économie
mondiale de la préco vide avec une
sortie attendue cet après midi celle du
président russe vladimir poutine
on retrouve tout de suite notre envoyé
spécial à saint pétersbourg jean marc
sylvestre un jean-marc la présence de
vladimir poutine aujourd'hui à saint
pétersbourg est ce qu'elle vise à
rassurer les acteurs de l'économie russe
en période de qu'ovide
oui il vise à rassurer les acteurs les
investisseurs elle vise aussi à montrer
au monde entier que la russie et s'est
remise au travail a peut-être tourner la
page de la pandémie même si les risques
le rsa important la vie à peu près
normale a repris un peu partout à saint
pétersbourg et se traîne le table
notamment dans dans les soirées
même si dans des centres et des forums
aussi important que celui ci les mesures
de protection sont strictement appliquée
alors oui valley me retire a voulu
montrer que la russie existaient et
qu'elles avaient encore des chants il y
avait encore des possibilités et
notamment des ambitions de volonté nous
d'assurer un développement harmonieux
pour l'ensemble si vous voulez de la
coopération internationale contre et
manquer ce qu'il faut attendre du
discours de vladimir poutine cet après
midi
écoutez très concrètement vladimir est
attendu évidemment sur le terrain
économique pour rappeler la nécessité de
trouver une nouvelle coopération afin de
relever les défis de cette pandémie une
nouvelle coopération avec deux pôles
mondiaux les états unis d'un côté la
chine de l'autre mais aussi avec une
europe qui est un gros client mais
qu'elle est aussi un gros investisseur
et cet investisseur là il faut le
convaincre de venir et de revenir en
russie le deuxième point il ya eu sans
doute sur le terrain de la politique de
la santé avec le vaccin parce que en
russie comme ailleurs on est convaincu
qu' on ne sortira définitivement de ces
risques que par une vaccination
mondialement développer mondialement est
étendu le monde entier doit passer par
la vaccination
or ya un problème de méfiance ya un
problème de défiance à l'égard du vaccin
qui existent il faut donc conjurés de
cette question aération et puis le
troisième terrain c'est évidemment le
terrain politique partiel a dit mi-août
il est confronté à un certain nombre de
dossiers qu'il doit traiter la question
des sanctions ou des menaces de
sanctions qui hypothèque évidemment la
vie quotidienne des industriels pas
seulement des industriels russes année
également des industriels européens ou
aux américains qui sont d'ailleurs assez
nombreux le ici yahia la question des
rapports avec les états unis qui sont
très compliqué très tendu les rapports
avec la chine qui sont plus conciliants
parce que la russie c'est tourner plutôt
vers la chine
et puis ensuite il ya la question de
l'europe ouh là là encore là le dialogue
avec les européens
compte tenu du manque de coordination un
des partenaires européens doit être
reconstruit doit être retourné
jean-marc le président russe peut-il
donner des perspectives de sortie de
crise aux investisseurs du tissu
économique russe justement
[Musique]
alors vous savez tout va dépendre
exclusivement la façon dont son discours
va être perçue mais des investisseurs
ont bien sûr besoin de sécurité les ont
besoin de stabilité ils ont besoin d'un
certain nombre de garanties alors
l'admirent pétillant de la leur apporter
des garanties des garanties d'un
développement notamment avec des plans
d'équipement à long et moyen terme
notamment en infrastructures grands
travaux assainissement
la russie a d'énormes besoins dans ce
domaine et elle fait appel à des
industriels ou à des compétences et des
expertises étrangères et notamment des
expertises 1 française mais lui a dit
viens poutine doit aussi composer avec
des gouvernements occidentaux
or les rapports avec la mairie on le
sait sont très tendu les rapports avec
les européens
on le sait sont très compliquées cela
dit le dialogue n'est pas rompu et on
pense que dès le mois de juin vont être
prises des décisions qui pourraient
clarifier tout ça c'est encore assez
ambigu c'est encore flou pour l'instant
ça fait peser une hypothèque sur l'iss
les projets économiques et les projets
de développement
mais il faut combiner à la fois la
fermeté du côté russe et la prudence des
industriels qui eux veulent continuer à
se développer et de travailler merci et
jean marc sylvestre pour toutes ces
précisions en direct du forum économique
de saint pétersbourg en russie